Well, hi and welcome back. We're now starting Unit 5.
The topic of unit 5 is weighted graphs. I'd like to start up with a little magic trick.
You may have seen this sort of plastic ring structure before.
These are plastic rings that are use to hold six packs together and it turns out
and I'm going to show you pictures of it, but you can find them in the Internet.
They're very sad that maybe turtles can get themselves stuck in these holes
and then as they grow, they continue to grow but the hole doesn't,
and they can really damage themselves very badly.
It is suggested that you cut your six pack rings.
Actually introduce new cuts into this plastic structure so that is still connected.
It's not a bunch of little tiny pieces, but there's no more rings left in it,
and all the cuts have to be across little pieces of plastic
not long plastic or cross multiple plastics at the same time,
but each little bridges of plastic cut that and what I'd like you to do, follow me, let me show you.
Earlier today, I went to the supermarket and I asked them
if they'd be willing to give me one of this little plastic ring things.
In particular, apparently I got a very fresh one because it's nice and flat--it just sits here.
This wasn't actually going to hurt any turtles anyway.
Better I should got one from the dump but I don't think
my friends in Udacity would have like trash on their nice little pad here.
Here is a ring thing and what would I do is make cuts in the structure
so there's no rings left, but the thing is still in one giant piece.
Okay, I did it. Now at the end of the day your little plastic ring thing,
you should have a series of cuts on it and look there is no loops.
Any place that there's a circle that a turtle can get caught in, I cut it open,
but yet the thing is still in one piece.
Alright, so what you need to do is save the turtles.
You need to cut the bridges in this plastic structure until the plastic stays in one piece
but there's no loops, no turtle traps.
So you can make which ever cuts where ever you want,
but when you're done write the number in the box.
Don't tell me what it is. Just put it in the box.